ciao a tutti bentornati sanità stores
oggi nuova challenge con gremi però
questa volta dovrò nascondere io gli
ingredienti slime i treni dovrà
trovargli sei premi riesce a trovare
tutti gli ingredienti strymer riesce a
fare lo slime io avrò perso
se invece crini non riesce a trovare gli
ingredienti slime quindi non riesce a
fare lo slime io avrò vinto quindi devo
riuscire a nasconderli imposti in cui i
grandi non andrebbe a curiosare o
imposta in cui non si ma che ovviamente
creni può sempre prendermi per cinque
volte quindi perdo lo stesso segreti mi
prende per cinque volte anche se non è
riuscita a fare lo strike quindi
iniziamo a nascondere gli ingredienti mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace su
questo video
se questo fine raggiunge i 25 mila mi
piace farò la stessa challenge nascondo
gli ingredienti slime ma da un altro
personaggio a vostra scelta
portate queen del sondaggio quale
l'altro personaggio che vorremmo che
iniziamo allora innanzitutto apriamo il
cassetto delle mie colle singh lo so
sono tantissime e colore scelgo per
creni devo scegliere un colore brutto
qui
il look indovinate indovinate indovinate
che colore stai scegliendo ovviamente
scundi iscritti sempre ma alberto è
bellissimo bellissimo ma so 46 anche qua
dietro a me piace il verde il colore ma
solo che non mi piace lo sly inferte
ecco perché dico sempre che non mi piace
perdere non lo strike però il colore
terni
ma dopo forse andò troppo rumore treni è
entrata e appreso uno accollata al
cassetto quindi siamo già in svantaggio
e inutile che nascondo questa perché
premia già la colla come mettere gli
altri presenti a nascondere bene treni
sa benissimo che le cose sono nei
cassetti quindi the pupazzo allora la
soluzione balletti dove la nascondo
meglio che esco di qua stare attenta a
non farmi beccare vero
[Musica]
il ceco devo nascondere ciotola spatola
e bicarbonato pericolo dovevo mercato
ecco perché ho due bottigliette di
soluzione perdenti perché guardate
perché credi a un super udito ma è cieca
quindi è molto più facile per me questo
challenge
a meno che lei non senta dove sto
mettendo le cose
per questo la cercando di fare in più
silente possibile nascondere queste
barbera
[Musica]
ok dovrà posso vendere questo sotto il
termosifone
no non penso e forse nella libreria ma
già cavoletti di bruxelles
mi ha beccato non so se ho preso la lag
e il bicarbonato
non so se l'ha preso perché mi hai preso
però non so se ho visto che un bel no
non può averlo video però magari l'ha
sentito che ho messo fatto
l'impossibilità a nascondere le altre
cose le faccia mente perché ho solo
altre quattro possibilità e lei potrebbe
già avere la colla il bicarbonato
quindi ecco qua allora innanzitutto
nasconderla questa volta non va da
camera pensate lista sempre
[Musica]
che se metto la quale tana sopra
non so se ci arrivo sono un po persa
però brucia
[Musica]
ho sentito riscrivi ecco
chi di meno no era in giardino per lei a
me
meglio così marino sto un po esplorando
casa ce l'ho fatta vedete la sopra non
penso che i treni ciao berlina è un
pezzo che crini vi sia anche se credi un
po più alta di me però come farà a
vederla va sopra impossibile a meno che
non le cose in testa è stato
professionale questi del cuore devo
nascondere solo la ciotola però c'è un
po troppo silenzio è strano che crimi
non sta andando in giro a cercare gli
ingredienti
perché nascosta quella qualche parte
berlino far casino come sempre ho
trovato altre due paletti che secondo
addietro è meglio che il diavolo squadre
questo tutto
[Musica]
a metterla
detto
credimi ha preso di nuovo quindi io sono
tre possibilità adesso per fortuna sono
riuscita a recuperare la trottola
quindi dopo ancora nasconderla
maledetta gre b ha preso l'auto l'ha ma
non potevo fare niente altrimenti mi
becca va di nuovo
devo ancora meno possibilità quindi ora
green premia la colla e bicarbonato la
ciotola gli manca soluzione per lenti
alla paletta che è la sua sia mai
appreso della paletta e come pausa per
il dover forse è meglio se spesso la
soluzione per le in un posto più
difficile ma siccome ora ho già nascosto
tutti gli ingredienti cuore a parte il
timer
quindi se prendi non riuscirà a fare lo
slime prima che il timer scatà altro
finto io quindi cerchiamo di guadagnare
più tempo possibile
ovviamente non devo farmi prendere altre
due o tre volte non mi ricordo quante
altre possibilità o altrimenti perdo in
ogni caso
[Musica]
lamento qua
mi riguarda se a questa festa
[Musica]
per screditarla perché qua e molto buio
forse 3000 nel corridoio sento il rumore
della mazza vediamo qua sei riuscito
se riuscita a prendere il bicarbonato no
guardate e ancora quando ascolto che
qualcun altro che non lo ha preso ancora
merlino sabato inizia così rumore come
sempre io devo riuscire a guadagnare
tempo così avanti
[Musica]
mi ha preso un'altra volta ma quanto è
difficile passaggio in più bello io sto
facendo un sacco di rumore tempo
controllarsi bicarbonato già lavora per
controllare venendo comunque se trovo il
bicarbonato ha travolto tutti gli
ingredienti non le faccia fare lo slime
in qualche modo devono farle qualche
prima che ci riesco
tu la paletta ascolta deve aiutarmi di
riforma che premi non faccia stremo
capito aiutami marino
[Musica]
[Applauso]
chi fa mi ha fregato
grazie per lì non lo so che tu mi vuoi
dare i balzini però è un po strano
svegliarsi con te che milan chi l'ha
fatto
ho perso un'altra volta quindi questa è
la mia ultima possibilità sarà
difficilissimo anzi devo sbrigarmi
perché i gremi ha tutti gli ingredienti
quindi è in tempo per fare uno slam
scoperto
sarà forse il corridoio fino qua
non sa fare
[Musica]
gray è certo ma che cavolo stava
combinando guardate 20 bicarbonato non
so nemmeno se le sarebbe insistono
questo bicarbonato tre classi questa
volta ce l'abbiamo fatta anche se
pensavo fino all'ultimo che non ce
l'avremmo fatta perché davvero molto più
difficile questa challenge mi raccomando
lasciato un bel mi piace e se non avete
ancora visto i gestori sulla serie
animata andate a vedere il primo
episodio vi lascio la casellina cui
cliccate sulla caterina che preferite e
buona visione
ciao
[Musica]